sin cansancio y con una figura discreta
a ti guillem guita luchado duro para
asegurarse de que el sufrimiento por el
asesinato de su prometido ya mal caso no
quede en el olvido con la
desclasificación de un informe de eeuu
que afirma que el príncipe saudí
mohammed bin salman aprobó el asesinato
de caso vi
la académica turca simplemente tuiteó
justicia para llamar una petición de la
que se han hecho eco defensores de los
derechos humanos incluyendo aquellos que
han solicitado al gobierno
estadounidense a hacer público sus
informes de inteligencia sobre el caso
el hecho de que el informe haya sido
desclasificado es bueno porque esta
información había sido ocultada por la
administración trump esta administración
cubrió el rol del príncipe en el
asesinato pero como digo no es
suficiente el príncipe tiene que rendir
cuentas tiene que afrontar sanciones que
se le congelen sus activos prohibiciones
de viajar la omisión del nombre del
príncipe en una lista de sancionados por
el asesinato atenuado algunos de los
elogios a bailén por desclasificar el
informe y no sólo por parte de
activistas pro derechos humanos algunos
demócratas han presionado por una mayor
rendición de cuentas
debemos asegurarnos también de que haya
consecuencias reales para las personas
como mohamed bin salman si no los
autócratas del mundo recibirán el
mensaje de que la impunidad es la norma
ubicándose en la delgada línea entre
ignorar la destrucción de la disidencia
a través del asesinato y pensar en los
intereses regionales la administración
baiden ha afirmado haber hecho un
movimiento en dirección a recalibrar su
rol y cuestionar sus alianzas a largo
plazo con arabia saudita pero washington
por el momento ha decidido mantener
relaciones con el príncipe de 35 años
sin terminar de desechar sus décadas de
vieja amistad con el reino saudita